economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida dos estadounidenses
ganaron el premio nobel de economía de
quiénes se trata hola buenas noches raúl
se trata de paul emmel kramer y robert
wilson quienes se se han dedicado al
estudio de las subastas este
procedimiento se usa más de lo que
creemos raúl desde quien recoge la
basura hasta el precio de la
electricidad todo se rige por subastas
ahora y lo que hicieron estos dos
investigadores de la universidad de
stanford fue usar juegos para
entenderlas mejor y para hacerlas más
simples pero bolt y roberts además de
colegas son vecinos o raúl y se
enteraron del premio de una forma muy
particular
cometí el error de pensar que era una
llamada política y desconecte el
teléfono entonces llamaron al celular de
mi esposa todo fue cómico porque paul
milgram que vive cruzando la calle había
apagado todos sus teléfonos para que el
comité del nobel no pudiera comunicarse
con él así que tuve que hacer carne y
llamar a la puerta en pijama para
despertarlo
qué es
es una linda noticia bastante
sorprendente
qué emoción andar y al despertarse con
esa noticia y le pregunté entonces ahora
que hay conclusiones de la visita de una
misión del fondo monetario internacional
argentina ellos estuvieron entre el 6 y
el 11 de octubre en ese país para
allanar el camino de cara a una posible
reestructuración de deuda por 44 mil
millones de dólares el fondo monetario
internacional dijo que enviara una
segunda misión en noviembre para iniciar
discusiones formales sobre el programa
de ayuda una de las conclusiones es que
la profunda recesión ha provocado un
aumento de los ya elevados niveles de
pobreza y de desempleo cuyos efectos se
ven agravados por importantes presiones
en el mercado cambiario por eso advierte
el fmi que todos esos desafíos son
excepcionalmente difíciles y sin
soluciones fáciles a la vista así es y
este año no habrá la llamada 'tasa
google' para las grandes tecnológicas la
ocde tenía todo listo para que este
mismo año los gigantes digitales
tuvieran que pagar impuestos en los
países en donde operan
y no solamente donde tienen su sede
principal y sus clientes
esa iniciativa en la que están
involucrados 137 países quedó postergada
por lo menos hasta mediados de 2021 lo
que quieren es cobrar un impuesto que
consideran más justo y también impedir
que empresas como google facebook y
amazon entre otras
utilicen paraísos fiscales para pagar
menos eeuu es el que por evidente razón
y raúl no ha estado de acuerdo con esta
propuesta a mediados de este año se
retiró de las negociaciones y dijo que
había temas mucho más importantes en los
que pensar ahora y cambiamos ahora de
tema daniela porque el g20 está
analizando ampliar el congelamiento de
deuda a los países más pobres mire en
abril de este año el grupo de países más
poderosos del mundo les dio un periodo
de gracia de un año a 76 países pobres
pues para que puedan atender la crisis
sanitaria entre ellos de sant honduras
haití y nicaragua en américa latina pero
sólo 42 se han acogido a esta medida hoy
el presidente del banco mundial david
malpass reveló que se están evaluando un
nuevo plazo de seis meses adicionales
renovables pero también calificó de
frustrante la poca participación
acreedores privados entre ellos mencionó
por ejemplo a china que es el mayor
prestamista del g20 de los 744 mil
millones de dólares como vemos en el
gráfico que les deben los países pobres
a los de este grupo el 63 por ciento
corresponde al país asiático donde el
indicador es las tecnológicas impulsaron
hoy a wall street' sobre todo apoyo
previo a la presentación de su iphone 5
g este martes muy esperada en europa la
mayoría de las bolsas terminó con alzas
moderadas impulsadas por la esperanza de
que en eeuu van a probar estímulos
fiscales y en américa latina' relativa
calma en los mercados muchos de ellos
estuvieron cerrados por ser día festivo
raúl y para finalizar que nos trae como
cifra el día son los 113 mil 850 empleos
formales que recobró méxico en
septiembre esta es su mayor recuperación
laboral mensual tras haber perdido más
de 1,1 millones de plazas laborales por
la crisis del cob y 19 así de genial y
deja manera entonces llegamos al final
de ese bloque económico aquí en france24
muchísimas gracias a ustedes también
gracias por estar siempre conectados con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]